it is clearly now the will
of the parliamentary conservative party
that there should be a new leader of
that party and therefore a new prime
minister
boris johnson is stepping down as the
uk's prime minister unable to overcome a
string of scandals around unlawful
parties during the pandemic and broader
questions about his integrity
in less than three years he's gone from
this
[Applause]
to this
apologies to
everybody for the misjudgments that
i've made that we may have made
johnson enjoyed a steady rise from
journalist to london mayor to prime
minister despite gaffes that sometimes
led to accusations of racism sexism and
spreading misinformation
i'm sorry for the offence that i have
caused but i will continue to speak as
directly as i can
johnson was once considered the golden
boy of the conservative party
so how did he climb so high and why did
his premiership fall apart
to answer that question we need to
understand what sort of politician boris
johnson is
which means going right back to the
start
what are you not ashamed of though boris
whatever there is not to be ashamed
back when he was a political columnist
in the 90s johnson's early appearances
on the bbc's satirical current affairs
show have i got news for you brought him
national recognition and endeared him to
the british public that has been one of
his big selling points is that people
like boris johnson and find him amiable
and fun and that serves him very well
during his career
fantastic numbers to this rally it's
really really
his celebrity status made him one of the
most recognizable politicians in the uk
this helped him get elected to
parliament in 2001 and seven years later
he became the first conservative to win
the race for mayor of london
i know that there will be many uh whose
pencils hovered for an instance for an
instant before putting their ex in my
box
as mayor he found success focusing on
issues such as crime and public
transport he also reveled in promoting
the london 2012 olympics including the
infamous moment he got stuck on a zip
wire
but johnson had loftier ambitions
we should take the chance now as a
country to take back control take back
control take back control take back the
democratic control in 2016 johnson was
back in parliament and surprised many by
going against the leader of his own
party by backing brexit
i will be advocating uh vote leave he
quickly became a leading voice in the
campaign for the uk to leave the
european union which then won
the british people have spoken and the
answer is we're out the brexit
referendum and the following
negotiations with the eu ended the
careers of two conservative prime
ministers and paved the way for johnson
to take power
there will be people
around the place
who will question the wisdom of your
decision in october 2019 he called a
general election and led the
conservatives to their biggest victory
since 1987 allowing the swift passage in
december of his divorce deal with the eu
i think boris will get the brexit done
and people will not regret boris being
the next our new prime minister his
pitch to the public was
i'm going to use brexit this divorce
with the eu to sort of reset the way
that we do politics in the uk and bring
areas of the uk that has long been
forgotten about or brushed over by by
his predecessors
back to the forefront and and treat blue
coral work as better
johnson though would not be able to bask
in his electoral victory for long
the number of cases of kobe 19 outside
china has increased thirteen-fold it's
now a global pandemic in 2020 johnson
was faced with leading the country for
the coronavirus pandemic which has so
far caused the deaths of more than 180
000 people in the uk
the prime minister was criticized for
not acting quickly enough to prevent the
spread of the virus and for not taking
it seriously from the start
i was at a hospital the other night
where i think there were a few there
were actually a few coronavirus patients
and i shook hands with everybody at the
end of march johnson announced that he
had mild symptoms of the virus
i've taken a test that has come out
positive
and was hospitalized just over a week
later
he spent seven nights in the hospital
including three in intensive care
the pandemic in some ways played both
johnson's great strength and his great
weakness the great strength was that
he's an excellent communicator and he
really managed to rally the country
behind him and also pushed a very
successful vaccine program the downfall
was that he is a natural libertarian and
is known for being somewhat indecisive
and so
britain sadly suffered one of the
highest death tolls in europe from the
disease in part because mr johnson was
very reticent to lock the country down
johnson faced backlash when he admitted
to attending a party in downing street
during a period when people could only
meet one other person outside to prevent
the spread of coronavirus
mr speaker i want to apologize i
believed implicitly that this was
a work event some conservative lawmakers
defended johnson but many people across
the country who had abided by the strict
lockdown rules felt betrayed by the
prime minister i don't trust him anymore
no do i no there's no trust i think it's
an absolute disgrace to be quite honest
with you at this point i think he's kind
of lost his credibility as prime
minister a police investigation into the
events resulted in the prime minister
being fined though he resisted demands
to resign
i've paid the fine and i once again
offer a full
apology the revelations proved to be the
beginning of the end for johnson
in june he was booed by a crowd as he
arrived for a special jubilee service of
thanksgiving for the queen
[Applause]
[Music]
and only a few days after that he was
subject to a vote of no confidence by
his own party he survived but was badly
bruised around a third of conservative
lawmakers voted against him it's a good
result i certainly think it is because
don't forget that
uh you know when i first stood to be
uh leader of the conservative party in
2019 i didn't get anything like uh that
much uh support from my my colleagues
involved
were building that meanwhile johnson's
also accused of mishandling a series of
scandals around conservative lawmakers
misconduct i think it was a mistake and
i apologize for
for it i think in in hindsight it was
the wrong thing to do
and the party lost local and national
elections casting doubts over his
popularity with voters in july a flurry
of cabinet resignations including the
treasury chief and health secretary
rocked the government
we have reason to question the truth and
integrity of what we've all been told
and at some point
we have to conclude
that enough is enough
i believe that point is now
in the end boris johnson was undone
because
he was no longer viewed as an electoral
asset by mps but a liability and the
minute the lawmakers saw that johnson
was no longer likely to win them
elections they jettisoned him